kubernetes allows you to focus on the
applications that matter to you by
abstracting away clusters of underlying
infrastructure but when an application
is stateful meaning it needs to persist
data in some form it can be essential to
have greater control over that
underlying infrastructure the backup for
GK service ensures you can back up your
kubernetes workloads safely it provides
the ability to back up not only the
persistent volumes containing the data
for your apps running in kubernetes but
also the configuration of the GK cluster
itself another important functionality
in GK is upgrades gke has a few upgrade
tools that can help you run stateful
workloads with minimal disruption across
upgrades from backups to upgrades to
configuring storage to suit your needs
GK provides an ecosystem of solutions to
support the challenges of running
stateful workloads in kubernetes